is he feeling fit getting some juicy
thighs from the cycling
um I don't think my legs are really
growing that much but I definitely feel
like I'm getting more fit like cardio
wise
I I just conflated cycling with um the
endurance cycling
you know I'm talking about the Olympic
endurance biking where like around the
velodrome or whatever like makes your
thighs juicy as well yeah yeah I think
like yeah a lot of cyclists have big
juicy thighs yeah
yeah just because they're riding bikes
all day long it's pushing but I'm not
really getting juicy thighs they're kind
of the same size yeah
yeah yeah
these boys I was looking up fellow I was
just last week looking up velodrome
crashes
sick because I yeah yeah it is sick it
is it is [__] sick Luke actually can
you look it up because there's one I
want to show that's the point of
watching any race with wheels yeah
oh damn damn dude who wants to see a
still image of a crash this is why this
is why endurance cycling
isn't more well known as your production
as ass yeah right
[__] operators to like yeah yeah yeah
you've been working out
uh so Australia really [__] me up on
sleep and then
this [__] that I have right now I know I
got this in San Francisco so it's a long
way of saying no but I was on a [__]
I was on a good good run dude I had like
a PR like three weeks ago on squat nice
195. nice
I probably could have pushed like 205
but I've never squat that much weight so
I was just really scared to I was like
I'm gonna slip my body acclimate yeah
um
that was definitely one of those moments
where I put it up and I was like oh
like definitely probably could have been
squatting more
earlier in life just never tried it
definitely in a good place but
the eating part just hard to eat they
say corn soda is really good yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah for Fitness that's
actually what I'm on weight that's
myself that's my first meal is corn soda
with a scoop of protein powder
scoop of corn corn protein powder oh my
God imagine Ranch soda corn soda protein
powder Shake do we have a blender yeah
yeah I put all this you can toss all
this in a blender
protein oh
but yeah and why don't you go back on
tour
next Sunday oh sheesh no but I that
that's gonna be fine because man we I
think about all the time we [__] up
why we could have been
eating and we could have been yoked why
because all right
after like touring like comedy clubs
where you're just like in and out of
hotels and stuff I was still able to
figure out a rhythm and then I always
think like [__] if we dude we could have
loaded that fridge up with like [__] for
shakes yeah and if we killed like if we
didn't do meet and greets in some cities
it's so easy when you pull to a city you
just go to a gym pound out for an hour
come back you you like we could have hit
our calories could have been working out
three four times a week
you're hitting calories is not a thing
for me though well it is for me yeah I
know this one but that was my problem
was always eating too much oh so if we
had that [__] laying around I would have
gained way too much away probably no but
if we just replace the bad boy's drawer
with like a healthy [__] yeah that's
true I'm just saying we could have we
could have turned that into like
Iron City yeah what was in the bad Farm
what was in the bed
what wasn't in there yeah what wasn't
Tom what wasn't Tom putting in m m
peanuts we always had those on Deck we
always had a full sleeves of Chips Ahoy
yep every night yeah Oreos a lot of corn
soda brownies I mean dude yeah it was
bad all kinds of [__] in there it's
called that for a reason
yeah a little cocaine yeah yeah I like
how we're talking about it like there's
like really risky [__] in there yeah
it's just snacks yeah Oreos now honestly
there was a lot of [__] like definitely
we took a step towards diabetes
with what was in that drawer yeah I
would always start start like if I knew
we were going on tour I'd work out
really hard yeah and like eat well and
lose a bunch of weight and then I would
come back 20 pounds heavier
yeah every time bro
yeah well
I'm finally like I'm my body is like
just chilling at like 152 155 I'm I'm
skinny right now so I mean I've always
been skinny but I think end of the year
I'm aiming for like 160. nice I think
I'll get there yeah [__] yeah yeah dude
and then I'm gonna take up cycling but
I'm doing reverse I'll do it with my
hands what do you mean like I'm gonna
pedal the bike with my arms there are
bikes like that uh no but you can get
like a recumbent bike that you can no no
I'm gonna put my chest on the seat oh
nice and my legs up in there split yeah
yeah
like backwards like this junk is facing
forward no you can see for it like
no no I'll be I'll be look at these
things
no [__] actually I'll just be like in a
Superman pose like flat on the seat yeah
my legs yeah yeah
[Laughter]
super aerodynamic yeah I'll be working
out core yeah because I'll be having to
balance the bike
this is all to make my arms massive yeah
I mean that would work probably yeah
right yeah you just
just pounding your arms every day up a
hill yes yep
yeah exactly yeah
I always think about this when I'm going
down a hill
because they were already going like 40
miles an hour or something yeah and
doing this you know he was he was going
he must have been going I don't know 45
yeah 50. so scary and your points of
reference are
so much closer to your eyes so like
it feels like a hundred miles an hour
I've never seen this video you've never
seen this no yeah this went crazy on
Twitter
I'm not on cycling Twitter so
it's me and the Swatch group CEO
no you go on a bike with the Swatch
groups
yeah he does that to [__] establish
what the [__]
so it's just way more aerodynamically
yeah yeah that's insane why does no one
do this he must be going like 50 miles
an hour yeah holy [__]
imagine any little bump this is how this
is how the [__] Lance Armstrong won
those races dude yeah
like yeah he's not he's not pedaling
look at he's pissing too you can see the
yeah
he's about to beat him moped homie
dude he's ripping foreign
oh that's so freaky oh my God
how do you get your feet back on the
pedals this is terrible
terrible oh my God my God that little
speed wall dude the pedal yeah the
pedals are going so fast
oh easy boom that's impressive that's
crazy you know it was sick in Italy they
made pizza there
whoa yeah that's awesome yeah that's
crazy I also got this Tower
um be ashamed of a plane hit it no um
sorry
it's the American way all right
uh no we uh we went on this long bike
ride
through like the countryside in Tuscany
uh with some like e-bikes
and I love those things yeah oh so fun
there are some moments where uh
we did a lot of uphill
um which I think is probably a good idea
because if they we were on those e-bikes
we were going down those Hills see ya
why I would have gone straight off
something
you're still peddling though right yeah
it just has like pedal assist yeah isn't
that fun yeah but it had a best
invention it did but there was one mode
that was like super fast yeah yeah you
were barely pedaling it's just hitting
20 miles an hour on an uphill
if I was going down I'd be hitting 30 no
question did you did you get that sort
of like I don't know it's like you get
this special feeling when you're biking
like the scenery looks cooler you know
um yeah yeah definitely yeah yeah 100 I
love that